I'm Alex and this is a GameSpot news
update an article published on Neurology
now argues that excessive gaming can
fundamentally change the wiring in in
adolescence brain neurology now is an
official publication of the American
Academy of Neurology the articles main
focus revolves around the consequences
of dopamine on the teenage brain studies
show that gaming activates pleasure
centers in the brain releasing dopamine
and stimulating positive emotions over
time due to the abundance of dopamine
the brain responds by producing less
leaving players with a diminished supply
according to the author of this study
this can lead to behavioral problems
withdrawal symptoms and aggression the
article makes frequent reference to
Anthony Rosner a World of Warcraft
addict who could spend 18 hours a day at
his computer becoming a great hero in
game while neglecting his real life
responsibilities such as his schoolwork
relationships health and hygiene the
article says according to a study by the
mtv group his gaming obsession isn't
unique 9 out of 10 children play video
games well I work at GameSpot calm and
don't know anyone that games for 18
hours a day but regardless the article
goes on to say that gaming can have some
advantages games can require players to
think of strategies multitask and make
decisions with both short-term and
long-term consequences these skills are
relevant in many jobs today
so gaming and moderation appears to be
relatively healthy and advantageous and
playing for 18 hours a day
unhealthy got it get all your gaming
news at GameSpot calm
you